- Welcome everyone to Session AMZ306,
Elevate Streaming Quality with AI:
Prime Video's Innovative Approach.
So before we start, how many
of you watch Prime Video?
It's awesome.
So you might have seen the
latest shows like "Fallout"
"Ted Lasso" or like watched
"NBA" or "TNF" on there.
So this session will be really
interesting for you to learn
how Prime Video uses
AI, particularly GenAI,
to improve their artwork quality,
to be able to improve
the streaming quality
so that you can watch
uninterrupted movies,
uninterrupted sports on
your favorite channel
of Prime Video.
So to start off with, I'm Tulip Gupta,
I'm a principal solutions
architect with AWS
and I support the strategic
accounts under AWS,
primarily the media
attainments under Amazon
and Prime Video is one of my customers.
And I have with me Brian
and Mona from Prime Video.
Brian is a principal SD at Prime Video
and Mona a senior manager
of data engineering.
And they are going to
introduce themselves later on
when they present their use cases.
So we are going to start
up with an introduction,
go through all of the use cases
that Brian is gonna talk about
the artwork quality moderation
that he uses GenAI with.
And then Mona is gonna elaborate
on the streaming quality,
how they improve that using GenAI agents.
And we are gonna talk about
the challenges that they faced
in their individual journeys
as well as the solution and journey on AWS
and also like talk about the demonstration
and benefits at the end.
So when we talk about Prime Video,
Prime Video is global,
Prime Video has millions
of titles in its catalog
that it can stream on hundreds of devices.
They support over 30 different languages,
operate in more than 240 plus
countries and territories
and support over 200 million
Prime members worldwide.
So nearly anywhere around the world
you can log in onto Prime Video
and enjoy your favorite content.
So let's say you're
traveling to Europe or India
or anywhere like you'll be able to log in
and watch your favorite show out there.
Like basically like there's
315 million data points
that Prime Video has a
global ad supported reach
for over like 300 million monthly viewers.
And this is how Prime Video
has grown linearly over time.
So they started off like in
2016 with "The Late Show"
and then as you can see as they have moved
from like 2018 to 2020 to 2022,
they have increased
the number of streaming
that they have done,
number of shows that they have produced.
So it's a lot that's going on.
And so as they're scaling they
also want to be able to scale
how they are able to like use
it for the streaming quality
and how they're able to like reach it out
to like millions of customers out there.
So it's a huge accomplishment
and as they continue to
grow bigger and bigger,
scaling efficiently does
impact their ability
to deliver these events
over our "Swim Team"
and then lining up their biggest
or slate of critical movies ever.
And with Prime Video customers,
they can customize
their viewing experience
and find the favorite movies,
series and live events
including Amazon MGM
Studios produced series
and the movies "Fall Out."
And so in 2025 they also added, you know,
like the Fox 1 and Peacock
Premium Plus as well.
So it's been kind of a journey
as they've grown over time.
And so a little trivia out here.
So in 2025, what was the peak audience
for the Commanders versus
Packers Thursday night
football game on Prime Video?
Can anyoneanswer the question out here?
Any guesses?
18.
- 20.
- 18, so you can see
like how massive it was
like with like 18 million people
logging in at the same time
and watching the TNF game.
And so to operate at that
scale they also want to be able
to scale out the
infrastructure primarily on AWS
to able to meet that demands.
And so to kind of like talk
about what the use cases were,
you know, so they wanted
to be able to improve
and moderate the streaming quality
that Mona is gonna touch about
and then like also to be able
to moderate the artwork quality
that Brian's gonna talk about at scale.
Like when you talk about
the scale that we looked at
like and it goes up linearly.
To operate at this scale,
they depended on
solutions like GenAI tools
for evaluation and performance
and that's how they were
able to scale it out.
So like for example, for
like for Brian's use case
they get content from like, you know,
Peacock, from like Stars, you know,
PBS for NFL and MLB and NBA
and they are able to moderate
it by using GenAI tools.
And so if folks are aware
with some of the GenAI tools
out here, I'm also gonna cover
some of the GenAI tools
in the coming slides.
So when we talk about GenAI tools,
you might have heard about
AI agents particularly.
So what are AI agents?
And it's a tectonic shift of how we build,
deploy, and interact.
And so for an AWS we have
what we call our agents which is like,
and it's kind of a GenAI
agents that come out there.
These are like autonomous
or semi-autonomous software
systems that can reason,
plan, and act to accomplish goals
in digital or physical environments.
And so these, you know...
We had the foundation models
which can do one task.
But when we talk about agents,
they're able to do a task independently,
they're able to call the foundation model,
they're able to access database,
they're able to go and call tools.
And they're able to perform
that task on their own.
And so these can leverage
AI to reason and plan
and accomplish the plan,
the task on their own.
And so that makes sense
to what we think about
the evolution of agentic AI.
And so we move from left to right,
there was more human oversight
when we first started
with help of like generative AI assistance
and you might have heard about it
and two years ago when it came out,
they follow a set of rules,
they automate repetitive tasks.
And as we move towards the right
then we have the GenAI agents
that we touched about
in the previous slide
and they are able to do a
singular task very well.
And then we moved onto the
right is agentic AI system,
which are like fully
autonomous multi-agents
and they can orchestrate
between them to accomplish
a set of tasks
and so they can mimic
human logic and reasoning.
And so as we move from left to right,
there's less and less human oversight
and there's increasing autonomy.
And so when we talk about
AWS agentic AI portfolio
and for some of you it might be familiar
with something called SageMaker.
So SageMaker essentially it
gives you the compute power,
it gives you the model
where you can customize
your own model, you can build, you train
and you host your own models
and we also provide compute stuff
like Trainium and Inferentia.
Then we have the middle layer
which is AI and agent development
software and services.
And in this we have Amazon Bedrock.
How many of you're familiar
with Amazon Bedrock out here?
Cool, so for folks who are not,
this is the managed service.
Basically it gives you a
flexible comprehensive service
for GenAI application
and agent development.
It offers access to
like foundation models,
you can customers models
and you can application with your data
and apply safety guardrails.
So let's say you're building an assistant
that provides you move recommendation
and you say like, "Hey
you don't ask me questions
about politics," they
shouldn't be able to do that.
That's what we mean by guardrails.
And also like it provides you AgentCore
which is one of the new service we added
with essentially like helps you
scale, deploy your services,
operate at scale on AWS.
So if you build an application
and you want to scale
it out to like millions
and hundreds of users, AgentCore
is what we will be using.
And this is just briefly
touching about the services.
And then we have SDK for agents .
Like some of the one with NOVA Act
which is designed to like take
action within the browser.
And then we have Strands Agents,
which Mona and Brian are
gonna talk about it in deep
when they talk about their use cases
and how they have been leveraging Strands.
As the Strands Agents is
another open source SDK
that AWS has developed
and it basically is a
lightweight source SDK,
which helps you develop
agents very quickly
and be able to leverage
and call multiple tools to be
able to accomplish that task.
And on the top we have applications.
So these, as we moved on from broad term,
like obviously it gets,
you know, there it gets
more and more managed,
and you don't have to manage
your own infrastructure
like for Bedrock.
you do not have to manage
your infrastructure
and the applications you get
like a whole applications
out there that you can
like play around with.
So for example, like Kiro, it
acts like a coding assistant.
If you wanna develop an app.
Like hey I wanna Streamlit app
to act like a travel agent, it'll be able
to quickly design it and
build it out for you.
Then we have Amazon Q Developer
for accelerating software development.
Q Business for your data
and to answer questions.
Transform to accelerate
enterprise modernization of dotnet
and mainframe and VMware Clouds
and then Amazon Connect which
is to speed customer service
to delight customers.
And then lastly, Marketplace,
we can go and access a
lot of agents out there.
And just a quick brief overview for you
to like see all the portfolio out there.
And that brings us Strands Agents.
So we briefly covered
what Strands Agents is
in the previous slide.
So again, like I said, open source SDK.
So in the past like LLMs were a, you know,
we basically would
provide agents a template
of how to do stuff.
And right now LLMs are
getting smarter and smarter
and Strands Agents provides
a lightweight model
where it's more intuitive development
and it can figure it out to call the LLM
and the tools on its own
and it can get started in
minutes instead of hours.
And it provides you robust capabilities
like native tools, MCP servers,
and you can also like extend the support
for custom mobile providers,
custom tools and MCP.
So it helps you like with rapid
development and prototyping
and that's what the key thing
that Mona's and Brain's team
leverage to be able to experiment quickly,
to be able to use new services,
and be able to like iterate
on what they're developing
to develop that robust evaluation loop.
And with that I'll hand it over to Brian
to talk about his use case
and the artwork quality.
- All right, thanks,
Mona or thanks, Tulip.
So my name is Brian Breck
and I'm a principal engineer
with the partner experience
team within Prime Video.
We work with our content
creators like major studios
and independent filmmakers
to ingest their content
and prepare it for streaming customers.
That content includes not
only the streamable assets
but also artwork, metadata, trailers
and bonus material as a
part of that data set.
So just to get us started,
quick question for everybody,
how many of you, raise of hands,
stream with more than one device?
Probably most of you, it
looks like most of you.
So I stream with my
phone, my laptop, my TV,
my tablet and that creates
a lot of complexity
at Prime Video.
We have to support a
number of form factors,
backgrounds on top of 30 plus languages
and over 200 territories.
Now what we're gonna
be talking about today
is artwork quality.
We use artwork to
represent movies, TV shows,
channels, carousels.
And that artwork can show
up in the streaming site
as well as in marketing
material and advertising.
Now the artwork is
provided by our partners
and the artwork may be beautiful
but it may not meet the
needs of Prime Video.
So for example, we need to be able
to crop artwork depending
on what form factor
we're going to be showing it.
We also may need to overlay a logo
or an action button.
And so we need a safe zone on
the perimeter of the artwork
so that we can work
within those parameters.
So I've highlighted the
safe zone in purple.
In the first example
we can see on the left
there's plenty of text
on the side of "Lioness"
or plenty of space on
the side of "Lioness"
and on the right only the shoulder
of the last actor is being cut off.
So this is a perfectly
acceptable safe zone.
Now in the second example we can see that
a head is being cut off
for one of the characters
and there's some text
that's completely obscured.
So we could not use this for Prime Video.
Now this is just one type of
defect that we're looking for.
We're looking for other
things like mature content,
pixelation, issues with localization,
as well as accessibility for
things like colorblindness.
So we have a number of
challenges in this space.
One of the biggest is
that a lot of this work
is traditionally done manually.
So our partners provide
us a piece of artwork,
it needs to get into a
manual evaluator's queue,
they need to provide their feedback
and then that feedback needs
to get back to the partner
and there may be multiple
iterations of this.
So the entire process
can take multiple days.
Now our solution to
this generally has been
to create an ML model that we train
with artwork examples
and then we use those
examples to find defects.
But that's a time consuming process
and we have over 30 defects
that we're looking for today
in our artwork and that
number is only growing.
Now another problem that we have is data.
We have been collecting data
from our manual evaluators
on acceptable and not acceptable content.
However, they don't always
follow the same SOP,
standard operating procedure.
And so what may pass one
evaluator may not pass another
and that data can leak
into our our data sets
and make it more difficult to use.
And then once we have a solution,
the evaluation can take a
while, we can take several days
to run it over a data set
and then figure out what
changes need to be made
for the next iteration so that
we can improve the system.
Now when we're talking about evaluation,
what we generally do is we
take a few thousand images
and we have a human
annotator that goes through
and provides what the
correct result should be
and that's what we see with
the ground truth column.
Then we run our automated solution
and then we look for
discrepancies in the results.
So in this example in the
second image we can see
that ground truth says that
this should have passed,
but the model that we were
using is going to fail
that piece of artwork.
Maybe it thought that Ryan
Reynolds hair was too close
to the edge and so now we
need to provide more artwork
as training data to fall for this problem
or create some additional
instruction in our algorithm
to allow this to pass.
But we're only looking
at four images here.
Imagine if we're looking
at thousands of images
with results in S3 buckets
that we've gotta pour over,
it can just take a lot of
time to evaluate the results.
Now one of the things
that we noticed is that
with LLMs and their
multimodal counterparts
we can detect certain defects
with those foundational models.
We'd seen anecdotes of it
being used in other places
and so we wanted to try
it out for our use case.
So what we ended up doing is using Q CLI,
which is now folded into Kiro
to generate a few algorithms for us
and use a few different
foundational models
to try out some results.
We wanted to move quickly,
we wanted to make sure
that this was going to work for us.
When we ran the results,
we anecdotally saw
that it was promising.
So then we wanted to go
and perform one of the evaluations
that we just took a look at.
We saw that our precision
wasn't high enough
and we knew that we could improve it,
but we also knew that it was
going to take a few iterations.
So we wanted to move a lot
faster than we had in the past.
So what we ended up doing is creating
an evaluation framework that
we use for defect detection.
We take as input data
sets with ground truth
as well as some initial configuration
and then as output we get the results
as well as feedback on
how it could be improved.
Instead of diving into S3 buckets,
we can see views of the artwork.
So for example with "Uncharted"
we can see a mobile view versus a web view
and how that's going to look
in the different use cases.
And then we get some
benchmarking statistics
based off of how compared to ground truth
as well as how it
compared to previous runs.
And then we also have
the ability to dive in
and take a look at some of the issues
at the individual artwork level.
So here we're taking a look
at the backend architecture
for our evaluation system.
It is a system that is
orchestrated by Strands
with individual agents that
perform the defect detection.
They perform the evaluation of the results
and then also agents for
suggesting improvements to the process.
So the way that it works
is that a user will submit
an initial request through our CloudFront
and load balancer instances
and hit our API.
That API will store the
data in our config table
and that will include an initial prompt
used for defect detection.
It will include a link to a data set
along with the ground truth data.
And then it will also include
some initial configuration
such as which model to use
and some things like
temperature to determine
how to use that model.
Next the orchestrator will
pick up that configuration
and delegate each piece of artwork
to our eval subject agent
that will actually perform
the defect detection.
And once we've gotten through all of those
pieces of artwork, we write the results
to our S3 results bucket.
Once the results are written
we use our results calculator
to generate the statistics that
we saw in the previous slide
and we also use that data to
determine some next steps.
Finally, we will send
that data on both the results
from the defect detection
as well as the results
that were calculated
and send that to our prompt improver.
The prompt improver agent
will take a look at all of that data
and make determination on
what should be done next.
That could be making
changes to the prompt,
it could be suggesting
different models to use
or different configurations
for using those models.
Now once we've gotten
through that process,
that data is written
back to our config table
and then can be used for the next run.
I'll take a step back real quick.
So Strands is doing a few things for us.
At first it's simplifying
our interaction with LLMs.
Second, it is allowing us to
easily create relationships
with between agents.
And it also provides
some out-of-the-box tools
that we've been able to take advantage of.
So when we're talking about tools,
there's a few built in tools
that we use on a regular basis.
One would be the image
reader which allows us
to prepare the artwork
for the LLM when it's
initially being called
or the LMM.
We use file read and write
so that we can do intermediate
manipulation of the images
as a part of certain processes.
And then also agents as tools
to create those relationships
between the agents and be
able to call them explicitly.
On top of that we've also
created some custom tools.
So like the safe zone
example that we talked about,
we have a crop image custom tool.
We have also a transparency
check tool for readability
and accessibility and
that the set of tools
that we have available to us now
has grown significantly.
Now unlike the safe zone,
defect detection process,
not everything can be
a pass/fail or can we use that information
as pass/fail in order
to improve the system.
Sometimes we need qualitative results
as well as the quantitative
results in order to decide
what our next steps are.
So what we do is we create a judge
that takes a look at the
evaluation performance
and provides some additional
context for why things failed,
what could be done better on
that individual artwork basis.
And so what we do is we provide
some initial configuration
to our DynamoDB table for the judge.
The judge configurator
agent reads that information
and prepares it for the judge itself.
And then the judge will then take
a look at the results of the evaluation
and provide additional
context that can then be used
as a part of the prompt improver step.
Now we could use a judge
for all of our defects,
but it's expensive
and so we only add that configuration
and step when it's absolutely necessary.
But it has been critical to get
some of our defect detection
mechanisms in place.
Now overall Strands has greatly simplified
a lot of what we're trying to do.
It has made it so that we don't
have to move images around,
all of our interfaces are text based,
we can access the images centrally.
And we're also able to use the system
to run regression tests.
So if we want to change the model
or if we want to change the configuration
or a prompt, we can validate
that we haven't made things worse.
This has been so successful
that we've also started using it
for things like text.
So like I mentioned, we receive metadata
and so we have to
validate say the synopsis.
And so we have a bunch of
defects that we look for
in a synopsis that is running
through the same process.
So like I was saying before,
we generally use about 2000 images
and we have humans run through them
and provide the ground truth result.
When we initially started this process,
we were running into some
local maximums with precision.
We just weren't hitting
the values that we thought
that we should be able to reach.
So we were running into situations
where when we would fix one false positive
or false negative we
would cause another one.
And what we realized is that
as we started digging into the data
that the manual evaluators were
using inconsistent criteria.
Some of them would pass something
that others would fail and vice versa.
And so as a part of
this process we ended up
creating a standard operating procedure
for the manual evaluators
that would also be shared
with the automated system
and so we could have consistent results.
And those consistent results
led to a better ground truth data set.
And that better ground
truth data set allowed us
to run that loop that I was showing
where we could run an evaluation data set,
we could look for ways to improve it
and then run another evaluation set.
Basically creating a auto tuning mechanism
where it was completely
hands off the wheel
and we could just watch
the system improve itself.
And so that actually simplified
our runtime solution.
So we take the configuration
that we were generating
in our evaluation phase
and we load that into
an app config instance.
Then we allow our partners
to upload their artwork
through our portal, goes
through API gateway,
and then is delegated to modules
each representing a particular defect.
So we can run defect detection in parallel
and for each defect detection
mechanism we are reading
the configuration from the app config
in combination with providing
the artwork to Bedrock.
And we're able to generate
those results almost real time.
So where it would take
several days for the partners
to get the results back,
we're actually providing that
within a minute.
So when it comes...
So the solution isn't perfect
and so when the partner gets a result
that they don't agree with,
they are allowed to override that result.
So what that means is we recommend
that they make some particular update
and they think the artwork's fine.
So it goes into a manual evaluator's queue
and we'll use the old process.
But the great thing about
this solution is that
where we were reviewing
100% of the artwork
that was provided to us, now
we're only reviewing say 10,
12% of the artwork.
And that has been a huge time saver
for our manual evaluators.
So through this process,
starting with the Q CLI solution,
we were only at about 37% precision.
We were able to get that number to 78%
for the safe zone.
We were able to reduce false
positives and negatives by 70%
and we were also able to
reduce the amount of time
it takes to get results from several days
to less than an hour for
certain circumstances.
But most importantly
we were able to reduce
that manual effort by 88%.
So we learned a few things along the way.
First was don't try to
do too much at once.
The context windows have
been growing recently
and we initially tried to
take advantage of that.
We tried to run defect detection
for multiple types of issues
at once and found that
that was just not the way to go.
So what we ended up doing
was we broke the problem down
into the individual defect types,
ranked them by how often they occurred
and how much effort it was to
manually perform the detection
and tackle them one at a time.
The next thing that we learned
is that we can really use generative AI
throughout the lifecycle.
So we started off with our
initial proof of concept
being generated by Q CLI.
Then we used generative AI
to create our system design
for development and then for evaluation
and a lot of our monitoring.
So we estimate that we used generative AI
for about 85% of what I showed
for both the evaluation framework
and the production system.
And so it was a huge time saver,
saved months of engineering work.
We also found that LLMs are effective
at proving their own prompts.
So we used Claude to
take a look at prompts
that we were providing to Claude
and it was effective at telling us
where we could improve
things that were specific
to that particular model.
We also found it very helpful to establish
that robust evaluation loop.
So being able to just iterate quickly,
even when the changes that
we were making were manual,
we could just kick the process
off again, see how it worked
and not spend so much time
in the investigation phase
was critical for our success.
And last we learned that
manual evaluation is hard
and error prone and so it was worth it
to take the time to generate
a high quality data set
so that we can make sure
that our automated
processes are successful.
So we started off with the safe zone.
We've since moved to
logo and text placement,
offensive and mature content.
We're taking a look at text legibility,
localization and accessibility.
All of these things are
either in production,
being able to be used by our
partners or they are able
or they will be there
by the end of the year.
So that's the presentation.
It was great to be able
to share that with you
and I'm gonna hand it back to Tulip
who is going to continue.
- Thank you, Brian.
And so you heard from Brian like
how they were able to use Agent TKI,
how they were able to use
Strands Agents in their framework
to be able to moderate
their artwork quality
and be able to place
it at the right place.
And so that, you know, I
want to talk about agent TKI
a little bit more before
I hand it over to Mona
to talk about her story about
Strands Agents and GenAI.
So when we think about the two flavors,
one, you know, is basically
accelerating software development
where we talked about the
applications like Kiro
and Q Developer, helping
you to be the code assistant
and helping you code and develop apps.
And the second persona is like reimagining
business workflows with custom agents.
And this is where Mona's use
case becomes really important.
So they were able to use
a few agents out there
that were able to orchestrate between them
and create that custom workflow
to be able to accomplish
that goal that they need
which was improving the streaming quality.
And so this is the one
that we are gonna focus on
in the next use case that
Mona is gonna talk about.
And so briefly when we talk about
enterprise agentic AI applications,
we have our LLM in the
center, that's the brain.
That basically reasons,
that basically understand
and gives you the output
but it needs help.
Like when we talk about LLMs,
it probably doesn't have
the latest information.
So if you go and ask
any of the LLMs out here
like what's the weather in New York,
it wouldn't be able to answer it
because it doesn't know what date it is,
it doesn't know what the weather is.
So we want to give it some data points
and so the tools out
there help it call maybe
like a weather API or the current time,
some of the database can maybe shows you
like where New York is, things like that.
The information it needs to
be able to correctly reason
and give you that information.
It also probably needs memory to be able
to understand the current
information, current context
and conversation and take that action
and give you the correct prompt,
give you the correct answer like
oh it's 56 degree Fahrenheit in New York.
I'm not sure if it's 56
degree Fahrenheit right now,
but I'm just like saying it.
And also like another
important thing is observation
and guardrails where we want to ensure
that if you are asking it
for weather information,
it doesn't answer me like about politics,
answering me about like who
the current President of United States is.
So we want to be able to
restrict it to be able
to answer only for the prompt
or the context that we are asking it for.
And so with Amazon Bedrock
you're able to do all of that.
It provides you the
ability to access models,
it provides you ability
to call tools with MCP,
which is model context
protocol, that's been introduced
by Anthropic and A2A
as well, agent to agent
like how your multiple
agents can orchestrate.
Provides you frameworks
like Strands Agents
that we talked about,
CrewAI and LangGraph to be able to build
that agentic AI framework,
agent code to deploy your
agents at a scale on AWS
with your runtime gateway,
memory and observability.
And obviously it provides
you the ability to customize
and fine tune your models.
And with that I'll hand it over to Mona
to talk about her agentic AI use case,
how they improve streaming quality.
- All right, thanks, Tulip.
So quick show of hands,
how many of you have been
on call trying to use
a whole bunch of data to detect
localized mitigate issues?
Alright, I see a few hands here.
Well I'm very excited to
talk about our journey
of building an agentic workflow
to detect localize root cause
and mitigate streaming quality issues.
I'm Mona and I'm a senior
manager at Amazon Prime Video.
Prime Video is a global platform.
We stream high scale live
events, video on demand
and linear content for our customers.
Ensuring our customers are able
to watch their favorite content,
whether it is the Patriot
scoring a touchdown, go Pats,
or you know, Barcelona scoring a goal.
We want to be able to
obsess over our customers
being able to take in that moment.
Sometimes what can
happen is while streaming
to millions of customers,
even an interruption
for a brief moment can mean that thousands
or millions of customers are interrupted
from their viewing experience.
Traditional operational approaches
such as manual monitoring of metrics
or alternatively reactive root causing
just do not cut it at our scale.
We asked ourselves the question,
what must we fundamentally build a system
that's not just monitoring these metrics
but actively understanding these metrics,
learning from these metrics
and able to autonomously take
action towards these metrics.
And that's exactly what
we sought out to build.
Now a few challenges that
we had kind of kept in mind
and used as the guiding principle
while working through these systems.
First off, we wanted our system
to be able to have access
to a multimodal sort of set of data.
So this can include
things like time series,
infrastructure logs, player logs, graphs,
so on and so forth.
We also wanted the system
to not just have access
to this data but to actually
understand this data
and almost build an intuition behind it.
And finally we wanted to be able
to have the system accessible
to pretty much anyone in
the engineering teams.
So this did not require special expertise
or domain expertise when it
came to understanding our data.
With that in mind, we went ahead
and built an AI agentic system
that sort of put together multiple agents
that were orchestrated using Strand
to be able to accomplish these tasks.
One of the qualities of the
system is that it can reason
through complex tasks,
break them down into multiple simple tasks
and then chain them together in a sequence
to accomplish the set task.
We also made sure that the system
was not just a one and done
but was constantly learning
from all of the data around it,
keeping the most current
operational snapshot of the data
and also be able to sort of actively learn
from any past mistakes or
feedback that it received.
So with that, let's take
an overall 30,000 feet view
of what the architecture looks like.
This system was built as an AWS native
as well as an AI native system.
It sort of orchestrated with Strands,
uses AWS Lambda for
things like authentication
as well as things like orchestrating
across the different agents.
As well as uses Athena both
for querying as a data store
as well as DynamoDB for some
of the global state management.
This system is the
foundational backend system
that can be used for a multitude
of different frontend interfaces.
So it can be used for example
as a chat bot interface
where somebody can put in
a natural language question
and be able to get an answer.
It can also be used to sort
of autonomously be triggered
by a different system that
maybe has detected an issue.
So really a bunch of different,
you know, sort of use cases
that can be facilitated with
the same backend system.
So diving into the components
of the system, as I said,
this is a multi-agent system.
We have a bunch of different
agents as well as sub-agents
kind of working together to be able
to accomplish the task.
First off, we start by looking
at the request handler.
The request handler is sort of
the front gate of the system.
What the request handler does
is once it receives a request,
it'll first go ahead and
authenticate the request,
then it'll validate the
request and then it'll go ahead
and start to decompose this
request into simpler tasks.
So for example, if the question asked was
what was the rebuffing rate
on iPhone devices in Germany
over the past week?
The request handler will
sort of break this down
to understand, okay, this
ask involves a metric ask,
it involves a trend analysis ask,
and then it also involves an
ask for a specific cohort.
Cohort being devices,
geographic information and time periods.
The request handler also
has a guardrail agent
as you heard from Tulip previously,
that's sort of able to validate
and make sure that the
request is compliant
with what the system
is supposed to support.
Now that we have kind of talked
about the request handler,
let's look at what happens after that.
Suppose the request handler
is the routing agent.
You can think of the routing agent
as an intelligent orchestrator
or sort of a traffic controller
that based on the request
that it got from the handler
sort of tries to understand
what are the different capabilities
that need to be invoked
to be able to serve as this request.
So the routing agent kind of understands
what those capabilities are
and sort of passes that along as a signal
to invoke other sub-agents, agents, tools,
data sources and so on.
So it can be really thought
as the brain of the operation
once it gets that decomposed request.
The routing agent also uses
the chain of thought process
in terms of breaking down a complex task,
kind of reasoning through
it like a human would
and then finally understanding
what are the capabilities
that it requires.
From the routing agent,
we then have the integrator subagent.
The integrator subagent can be thought of
as some sort of a traffic controller.
It's sort of, you know,
once it has got the request
from the routing agent, it
knows what specific tools
and data sources it needs to connect to.
This integrator subagent
sort of works through MCP,
which is model context protocol,
and is able to talk through
a host of different tools
as well as data sources
and is able to work
through things like different
access patterns, APIs,
access formats, so on and so forth.
It's also able to kind of combine
a bunch of these data together
by knowing the right joint
conditions and so on.
The other thing about
the integrator subagent
is that it also sort of
serves as a data quality check
and makes sure that it's
only the right kind of data
and the right quality of data
that is accessed by the system.
Post the integrator subagent,
we then have what is
the analysis subagent.
The analysis subagent
can really be thought of
as a data scientist in a box.
The analysis subagent is
primarily based out on Bedrock
and it has a whole bunch of
both large language models
as well as small language
models that it can access
in order to be able to
service a specific request.
You can really think of this
as sitting in an ensemble
of different models
and sort of leveraging the
right models per the use case
and per the capability that's needed.
Now once we have talked
about the analysis subagent,
the next thing that we have
is the reasoning agent.
So the reasoning agent sort
of takes all of this input
that it has received from
sort of the prior agents
and sub-agents
and what it does is it kind
of uses business context
that it has access to
to be able to determine
if the sort of analysis
that it has been provided
is sort of, you know, pertinent
and is sort of relevant with
all of the business context
that it has.
So this can be thought of
really as you know, sort of,
it uses an iterative approach
and uses LLMs as a judge to be able
to use an independent LLM to
kind of validate the responses
that it has received
from the previous analysis
agent for example.
And using that business
context is able to tell,
okay, is this really the sort
of, you know, expected answer
that I would have or would
it be something else?
The reasoning agent also has the ability
to sort of have an iterative
loop to kind of go back
and request a different capability
or invoke a different data source
based on what it might have
gotten from the LLM as a judge.
From the reasoning agent,
we then have the response handler.
So the response handler kind of takes
all of the different input
that it is received from the,
you know, routing agent,
the reasoning agent
as well as if at all you
had to run, you know,
multiple iterations of the loop
that we have just talked
about and really packages
all of this information together
into the expected output format.
So this could be things like the response
to a natural language question,
it could be generation of a complex SQL
or alternatively it could
also be an autonomous action
or a mitigation lever
that can be pulled in the
response to a certain trigger.
The response handler also interacts
with the guardrail agent,
again to sort of make sure
that the response is compliant
with sort of, you know,
the required sort of data sharing
and you know, other
such sort of activities.
Separately from that, the
response handler can also sort of,
you know, goes ahead and
logs all of these decisions
that it has made similar to what
all of the other agents have.
So it kind of takes all of these
logs which can then be used
for sort of, you know, reflective analysis
in terms of improving some
of the decision-making.
So taking a step back and
kind of looking at the system,
you know, overall, what
we talked about, you know,
first off was the request
handler that takes in a request,
sort of validates it,
make sure it's the right
sort of format,
decomposes it into the
sort of simpler tasks,
moves that along to the routing
agent that then sort of,
you know, knows which capabilities
it's going to need to invoke.
From there, it goes to
the integrator agent
which can orchestrate a
bunch of different tools
and data sources followed
by the analysis agent,
which is really the
data scientist in a box,
ensemble of LLMs that can be used.
Finally the reasoning agent
that kind of uses business context
along with what's given from
the analysis agent to make sure
that it is sort of an
acceptable and reliable answer.
Along with that it can
also trigger reiterations
of the loop, invoking other capabilities
and invoking other data sources as needed.
And finally the response handler
that packages all of this
and makes it available either
as some sort of an output
or a mitigation lever
or an autonomous action.
As you can see we also have
both an online evaluation system,
so similar to the LLM as
a judge that I mentioned,
as well as an offline evaluation system
that kind of takes all of
these logs of decision-making
and can be used sort of iteratively
in terms of understanding
and improving the system.
Alright, so now that
we have kind of talked
through overall components of the system
and how it works in real
time to be able to sort of,
you know, help detect, localize,
as well as root cause issues.
Taking a step into some of
the lessons that we learned
through the process of
developing the system.
First off, you know, data quality
always beats data quantity
when you're trying to
develop such a system
it can be sort of, you know, there can be
a whole lot of things that
you might want to add.
Things like infrastructure
logs, metrics, past incidents,
you know, tickets, so on and so forth.
But you really want to
make the most efficient use
of your context window
and make sure that you're
giving the right set of data
and data that will actually
get you to the right outcomes.
So being judicious in terms of the data
that you sort of have
as part of the system
is especially important.
The next thing is building
feedback loops early and often,
this really helps in the
efficiency of development
as well as the efficiency
of getting your system
to the levels of accuracy
and levels of reliability
that you're looking for.
The other one is planning
for failure modes.
You know, systems do fail,
we want to have an autonomous system
but there are going to
be times when you might
want to have sort of human evaluation
or when you might want to have times
that the system is just,
you know, sort of exposed
to a brand new situation.
So you do want to have safe
ways that the system can fail
and trigger the right sort of, you know,
human involvement as needed.
And finally continuing to use
AI to amplify human expertise,
whether that is understanding
the business context better,
data better, so on and so forth.
You always want to have AI
amplifying human expertise
throughout the SDLC software
development lifecycle process.
In terms of what's next for our system,
we want to continue to build
more mitigation levels,
sort of have more and
more autonomous actions
that the system is able
to perform by itself.
Continuing to use AI
through the software development cycle
in terms of accelerating our development
in terms of having quick prototyping,
using things like SageMaker,
as well as Strands for quick orchestration
and quick proof of concepts,
as well as using AI in the deployment,
as well as the overall
maintenance of the system.
And finally having more
and more safety mechanisms
so that you continue to not only build
but also keep trust in your system
and sort of have it leverage
more and more autonomous actions.
So with that I will hand it over to Tulip.
- Thank you, Mona.
So let's see how many of
you were paying attention.
What was the peak audience
during the commanders
and the Packers game in 2025?
Does anyone remember?
- 18 million.
- That's right, yes.
So you heard from Mona and Brian
about how they were able to
use GenAI in their solutions
in their use cases respectively,
and how they were able to,
if you remember that agentic AI evolution
from like going from a
more human oversight,
less human oversight
and be able to automate
a lot of those tasks.
And so both of them wanted to
be able to, for the use cases
where their main thing was
to deliver premium video
and artwork to scale to
millions of customers
across thousands of different devices.
And obviously when
you're trying to do that,
there's millions of customers globally
and you're streaming content 24/7.
And you want to be able to...
And it can impact thousands
or even millions of viewers
instantly if you're not
doing the right job.
So they wanted to ensure
like none of their customers
of Prime Videos are impacted
while they're trying to experiment,
while they're trying to like
see how it is being delivered.
And so that's where automation
using AI helped them.
Like they were able to
do it more precisely
with increased productivity
because there was less human oversight.
They were able to make
those agents do the work
and be able to experiment
it faster and faster
and be able to get the
output that they need.
And so their first key
takeaway is more automation,
the reduced evaluation time.
And you heard from Brian,
it took them days before
and they were able to like
reduce it to 15 minutes
and maintain performance
without human intervention.
And so like going from again,
that slide from like
going from right to left
with more human oversight
to the less human oversight.
They were able to scale smart.
So what they did is break
out problem into small chunks
and then scale out.
So if you have a bigger use
case like they wanna achieve,
you break it out into smaller
chunks, iterate on it,
work on it, AI agents,
and then build a multitude of agents
to do the orchestrated across
and then be able to accomplish
the goal that you need.
And have a robust evolution loop.
And so whatever you build
and whatever you wanna do,
even from Monas and Brian's use cases,
they were able to like
enable rapid iteration
and continuous improvement
through all of their process
because they had a robust evolution loop.
Whatever they were
building, they were able
to like validate the agent's outcome,
see if it's the right one,
and then basically improve
their agents as they went on
with their experimentation.
So I'll leave with this
like quote from Andy Jassy
who recently said, "What
makes this agentic future
so compelling for Amazon,
is that these agents
are going to change the scope and speed
at which we can innovate for customers."
And that's true, we are working on it.
That's the agentic future
that we look at at Amazon
and that's the scope that we
look at when we talk about it.
So if you are here,
right around the corner,
there's the One Amazon Lane
as well where you can see
some of the other use cases
that we have out there from Prime Video.
So we have the Extra
Recap, we have Rapid Recap
and a NASCAR Burn Bar which
kind of like shows you
some of the sport
innovations that we have done
as well as like extra recap,
if you watch Prime Video,
when you watch a movie or
you watch a TV episode,
it allows you to basically
kind of like show you
what the scene is about
and you can go and recap
and summarizes it.
So that's out there in the
demo at the One Amazon Lane.
On top of that other demos as well,
like the Zoox robotaxi.
So if you're out here,
I would highly recommend
just passing by it and check out
from some of the cool demos from Amazon,
including some of the
ones from Prime Video.
And with that I'll end the session
and if you have enjoyed the session,
you know, please complete
the session survey
in the mobile app.
We look forward to your feedback
and we obviously work off your feedback
to improve our sessions as we go.
So thank you so much for
attending the session.